MARTIN OMANDER: My guest
today is Joe Born, co-founder
of the startup responsible for
the Hale Dreamer alarm clock.
Joe, thanks for
coming on the show.
Would you tell us a
bit about your startup?
JOE BORN: Thanks for having me.
So yeah, we're a
hardware company that
was started to support the
underserved Android accessory
market, particularly on speaker
docks and nightstand docks.
So we released the first
speaker dock for Android plug-in
with a remote control.
And we released
the Hale Dreamer.
So a nightstand dock
with a smart silence,
do not disturb feature,
and a working snooze bar.
And we recently
became [? Iowa ?] USA,
so there will be lots of
announcements coming up
with that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Congratulations.
So how can a domestic hardware
startup like yourselves
compete with overseas
commoditized hardware?
JOE BORN: Yeah, so
it's a great question.
My biggest piece
of advice is don't
compete with
commoditized hardware.
Add your value on top of
that commoditized hardware.
And then leverage
that supply chain
so that you're adding value
and not getting too bogged down
in the details of the
hardware and competing
with the commoditized side
of the hardware, if you will.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
are you following
your own advice for this device?
JOE BORN: Yeah, so if you
look at this from a hardware
perspective, this is largely
an average commoditized speaker
dock, if you will.
It has got great sound and
buttons and charges your phone.
But the real value added, what's
really unique is in the app.
So the app has this
included alarm clock app
that actually silences
your phone at night
with smart sound.
So at a touch of a button
all your notifications
are silenced.
It can even reach back
to callers and say,
is this an emergency?
If they say yes, then it rings.
All that stuff is in software.
And so we really
did stub out a lot
of the details of the hardware.
Now in this case, it's
not just a sensor.
The speaker quality
was really important.
So we had to get
kind of more involved
than potentially some other
app with sensor app wrapped
in plastic might have to.
But we definitely leveraged
a factory and their expertise
to get this product to market.
And we didn't put
huge investments
on just the commoditized side
of the hardware, if you will.
MARTIN OMANDER: Tell
me more about that.
You said you leveraged
the factory's expertise.
So you are not just using
any old factory out there.
You go for specific
hardware partners?
Tell me more.
JOE BORN: Yeah, that's right.
The factory, for example,
that produces this,
supplies some very big-name
tier one acoustic manufacturers.
So a lot of acoustic expertise.
A lot of acoustic
equipment that they
bring to bear on our products.
And in fact, our
manufacturing arrangement
is much more of a partnership
than just a straight contract
manufacturing sourcing.
And the reason we do
that is because we do
get to leverage so much of that
expertise and the resources
that they have.
And that allows us to
focus on the things
that we really feel
we're adding values.
The details of this app, the
user experience, the design,
the things that really
touch consumers.
And that focus is what
allows us to do well at that.
MARTIN OMANDER: So then
does that mean you actually
have to pitch your product
not just to investors
and consumers, but to
hardware partners as well?
JOE BORN: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, most of the
factories that we
work with are full-service
factories that really
are seeking high-volume
successful products.
They don't make money
from design fees.
just from upfront stuff.
They really make money by
having successful products.
And so it's our job
to convince them
we have a winner with
this product concept.
And you should work
with us and partner.
And bring your resources
to bear and help us
so that we'll have a
successful product together.
We'll all make money.
There are whole categories of
factories that work that way.
MARTIN OMANDER: Really?
So you've been in hardware.
You have 20 years of
hardware experience.
How have you seen the hardware
field change in that time, Joe?
JOE BORN: It's
absolutely night and day.
To the extent that my
experience of a decade
ago is almost irrelevant.
And I would counsel
any of your viewers
to be very careful who they're
getting experience from.
Because if it's old,
it's much less relevant.
We have seen barriers
drop from what
cost us millions of
dollars to bring a hardware
product to market
even 10 years ago
to what's almost nothing today.
We used to have to do all this
engineering work ourselves.
Hardware, electrical.
And today you can put
together components
from Arduino, Raspberry Pi,
all this off-the-shelf hardware
and software that
allows you to assemble
a product in a fraction, a
real fraction of the time it
used to cost.
And then on the
sales side, you've
now got all these self-service
marketplaces like Amazon
and eBay and so on and so forth.
And crowd funding.
Whereas it used to
be all big brick
and mortar national retailers.
Altogether the barriers
to entry have dropped so
precipitously as a
result of those factors
that there really
is no comparison.
MARTIN OMANDER: Really?
So how are you
using those trends
to your advantage
for your startup?
JOE BORN: Well, we
certainly put together
the prototype using Arduino
and off-the-shelf speakers.
And that got us in front
of consumers and customers
much, much earlier than
we would have previously.
And then we did do a
crowdfunding campaign
to get feedback from the market
even before the product was
in production.
So we're using a lot of
those tools to our advantage
just like any other
startup should.
MARTIN OMANDER:
So are we looking
at a piece of Arduino
technology here?
JOE BORN: It was.
The original prototypes
were made that way.
We actually did shift to an
even lower cost microprocessor
because pennies do matter when
you get into mass production.
And another thing is that,
again, working with the factory
and they're leveraging
your supply chain,
managing your parts,
it's good to have parts
that they're familiar
with, relationships
that they have with
microprocessors.
Many of these silicon parts
have 16-week lead times.
So if you're working
with something
that they're familiar with
and a distribution chain
they're familiar
with, it's much easier
to get flexibility out of it
than if it's an unknown silicon
supplier, for example.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
yet another reason
to pick your hardware
partner with care
and make them a partner
rather than just
a manufacturer for you.
JOE BORN: Absolutely.
I mean, their ability to
apply financial resources,
their ability to apply
the relationships
are all crucial to things.
Imagine a new product
with an unknown demand
managing a four-month
lead time on it.
Virtually impossible.
So your factory really
can facilitate things
like that if you work with
them properly and choose
the right partners, you see.
MARTIN OMANDER: So is your
advice to other hardware
startups to use
Arduino, Raspberry Pi,
that sort of ready-made
technology for the prototype?
And then in
production, move over
to cheaper hardware
like you did?
JOE BORN: Absolutely.
And the other piece of
advice I'd give-- if you can,
use standard interfaces.
So we had a
proprietary interface
because we wanted a plug-in
dock and the details
of our implementation.
But if you can use something
that's cleaner like a Bluetooth
low energy, it makes
it that much easier
to manage the factory
at a high level.
So I don't need to know
all the details of what's
under the hood on my
pedometer, my scale,
or whatever it might be,
because the interface
is so well established.
And that, again, allows
you to give the factory
the flexibility to do their
thing under the hood, which
helps them manage their supply
chain and their inventory
costs, and their
engineering time,
and all that kind of stuff.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Very good.
Thank you so much for
coming on the show
and sharing your
experiences with us, Joe.
JOE BORN: Absolutely.
Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read all of them.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like
to be on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it.
See you next time.